what is
planet nine planet nine is
an object that we believe lives in the
solar system beyond the orbit of neptune
it orbits the sun
with a period of about 10 000 years
and uh is about five earth masses
so that's a hypothesized object there's
some evidence
uh for this kind of object there's a
bunch of different explanations
can you give like an overview of the
planets in our solar system how many are
there
what do we know and not know about them
at a high level
all right that sounds like a good plan
so look the solar system
basically is comprised of two parts the
inner and the outer solar system
the inner solar system has the planets
mercury venus
earth and mars now mercury is about
40 percent of the orbital separation
of where the earth is is closer to the
sun venus
about 70 percent then
mars is about 160 percent
further away from the sun than is the
earth
these planets that we uh one of them
we occupy right are pretty small okay
they're
two leading order sort of heavily
overgrown asteroids
if you will um and this is
this becomes evident when you move out
further in the solar system
and encounter jupiter which is 316 earth
masses
right 10 times the size um
you know and saturn is another huge one
90 earth masses at about 10 times
uh the separation from the sun this is
the earth and then you have uranus and
neptune
at 20 and 30 respectively for a long
time
that is where the kind of massive
part of the solar system ended but
what we've learned in the last 30 years
is that
beyond neptune there's this expansive
field of icy debris a second
icy asteroid belt in the solar system a
lot of people have heard
of the asteroid belt which lives be
between
mars and jupiter right like that's a
pretty common thing that people
like to imagine and draw on lunch boxes
and stuff
but beyond neptune there's a much more
massive much more
radially expansive
field of debris pluto by the way it
belongs to that
second you know icy asteroid belt which
we call the kuiper belt it's just a big
object within that population of bodies
oh pluto the planet
pluto the the dwarf planet the former
planet you know
why is pluto not a planet anymore i mean
it's tiny
we used to size matters when it comes to
planets 100
100 it's a actually a fascinating story
when pluto was discovered in 1930
the the reason it was discovered in the
first place because astronomers at the
time were looking for a seven
earth mass planet somewhere beyond
neptune
it was hypothesized that such an object
exists when they found something
they interpreted that as a seven earth
mass planet
and immediately revised its mass
downward because they couldn't resolve
the object with the telescope so it
looked like a just a point mass
you know star rather than the physical
disk they said well maybe it's not seven
maybe it's one
right and then sort of over the next um
you know i guess 40 years
pluto's mass kept getting revised down
downwards downwards downwards until
uh it was realized that's like 500 times
less massive than the earth i mean like
pluto's
surface area is almost perfectly equal
to
the surface area of russia actually and
you know russia is big but it's not a
planet
well i mean actually we can we can touch
more on that that's that's another
discussion
uh so in some sense earlier in the
century pluto represented
kind of our ignorance about the edges of
the solar system
and perhaps planet nine is the thing
that represents our ignorance
about now the modern set of ignorances
about the edges of our solar system
that's a good way to put it by the way
just
imagining this belt of astero of debris
at the edge of our solar system is
incredible
um can you talk about it a little bit
what is the kuiper belt
and what it what is the port cloud
yeah okay so look the simple way to
think about it is that if you
imagine you know neptune's orbit like a
circle
right kind of uh maybe a factor of one
and a half 1.3
times bigger on a radius of
1.3 times bigger you've got a whole
collection
of icy objects most of these objects
are sort of the size of austin you know
maybe maybe a little bit smaller if you
then
zoom out right and
explore the orbits of the most long
period kuiper belt object these are the
things that have the
biggest orbits and take the longest time
to go around the sun
then what you find is that beyond a
critical
orbit size beyond a critical orbit
period which is about 4 000 years
you start to see weird structure like
all the orbits
sort of point into one direction and
all the orbits are kind of tilted in the
same
way by about 20 degrees with respect to
sun this is particularly pronounced
in orbits that are not heavily affected
by neptune
so there you start to see this weird
dichotomy where there are
objects which are stable which are which
neptune
does not mess with gravitationally and
unstable object the unstable objects are
basically all over the place
because they're being you know kicked
around by neptune the stable
orbits show this remarkable pattern of
clustering
we back i guess five years ago
interpreted this pattern of clustering
as a gravitational one-way sign the
existence of
a planet in a distant planet right
something that is shepherding and
confining
these orbits together of course
right you have to have some skepticism
when you're
when you're talking about uh these
things you have to ask the question of
okay
how statistically significant is this
clustering and there
are many authors that have indeed called
that
into question we have done our own
analyses and basically
just like with all statistics where you
know there's kind of like
you know multiple ways to
uh do the exercise you can either
ask the question if i have a telescope
that has
you know surveyed this part of the sky
what are the chances that i would
discover
this clustering that basically tells you
that you have zero confidence right like
that's not
that does not give you a confident
answer one way or another
another way to do the statistics which
is what we prefer to do
is to take to say we have a whole
night sky of discoveries in the kuiper
belt
right and if we have some object over
there
which has ride tension and declination
which is a way to say it's
there on the sky and it has some
brightness
that means somebody looked over there
and discovered an object
of was able to discover an object of
that brightness or brighter
through that analysis you can construct
a whole map
on the sky of kind of where all of the
surveys that have ever been done
have collectively looked so if you do
the exercise this way
the false alarm probability of
the clustering on which the planet nine
hypothesis is built it's about 0.4
percent
wow okay so there's a million questions
here one
when you say bright objects why why are
they bright are we talking about actual
objects within the kuiper belt or the
stuff we see through the kupper belt
this is the actual stuff we see in the
kuiper belt the way
you go about discovering hyperbelt
objects is pretty easy
i mean it's easy in theory right hard
in practice yeah all you do is you take
snapshots of the sky right choose that
direction say and take
you know the high exposure snapshot then
you wait a night
and you do it again and then you wait
another night and you do it again
objects that are just random stars in
the galaxy
don't move on the sky whereas objects in
the solar system will slowly move
this is no different than if you're
driving down the freeway
it looks like you know trees are going
by you faster than the clouds right this
is parallax
that's it it's just they're reflecting
light off of the sun
and it's going back and hitting this
there's a little bit of a glimmer
from the different objects that you can
see based on the reflection from the sun
so like
there's actual light yeah it's not
darkness that's right these are just
big icicles basically that are just
reflecting sunlight back at you
it's then easy to understand why it's so
hard to discover them because
light has to travel to you know
something like 40 times the distance
um between the earth and the sun and
then get reflected back
was that like an hour travel or uh yeah
that's right that's something like that
because they
the earth to the sun is eight minutes i
believe um
and so something you know yeah yeah in
that
in that order magnitude so that's
interesting so you have to
like account for all of that and then
there's this huge amount of
data pixels that are coming from the
pictures
and you have to uh integrate all that
together yeah
to paint a sort of like a high estimate
of the different objects
can you track them can you be like
that's bob like can you like
yes exactly in fact uh one of them is
is named joe biden i mean i'm not like
this is not even a joke
right okay is there a trump one or no no
no
i don't know i haven't checked for for
for that but
uh like the way it works is if you
discover one
you right away get a license plate for
it
okay so like the first four numbers is
the first year that this object has
appeared on
you know in the data set if you will and
then
um there's like this code that follows
it
um which basically tells you where in
the sky it is
right so one of the really interesting
kuiper belt objects which is very much
part of the planet nine story is uh
vp113
because joe biden was vice president at
the time
you know got nicknamed biden
vp113 said yeah he got nickname button
beautiful
what's the fingerprint for any
particular
object like how do you know it's the
same one okay are you just kind of like
yeah from night to night you take a
picture how do you know it's the same
object
yeah so the way you know is it appears
in almost exactly the same part of the
sky
except for the move but it moves but
this is why actually you need
at least three nights because oftentimes
asteroids which are much closer to the
earth like will
appear to move only
slightly but then on the third night
will move away so that third knight
is really there to detect acceleration
now
the the thing that i didn't really
realize until
you know i started observing together
with my partner in crime and all this
mike brown
is just the fact that for the first year
when you make these detections
the only thing you really know with
confidence is where it is on the night
sky
and how far away it is okay that's it
you don't know anything about the orbit
because over three days the object just
moves
so little right the that whole motion on
the sky
is entirely coming from motion of the
earth
right so the earth is kind of the car
the object is the tree and you see it
so then to get some confident
information about
what its orbit looks like you have to
come back a year later
um and then measure it again interesting
to do three nights then come back
a year later and do another three nights
so you get the velocity the acceleration
from the three nights and then you have
the
maybe the additional the additional
information because an orbit is
basically described by six parameters
so you at least need six independent
points but in reality you need
many more observations to to really
pin down the orbit well and from that
you're able to construct for that one
particular object in orbit and then
there's
of course like how many objects are
there there's like
four-ish thousand now but
like the in the future
that could be like millions oh sure
oh sure so in fact these things are hard
to predict but there's a
new observatory called the vera ruben
observatory which is coming online
maybe next year i mean with covet these
things are
a little bit more uncertain but they've
actually been making great progress
uh with construction and so that
uh telescope is gonna sort of scan the
night sky
uh every day automatically and it's just
it's such an efficient survey that it
might uh increase the census
of the distant kuiper belt the things
that i'm interested in
by a factor of 100 i mean that would be
that would be really cool
and yeah that's a that's an incredible
uh
maybe i mean they might just find planet
nine
i mean that's like almost like literally
pictures like visually
i mean sure yeah like the first
detection you make all you know is where
it is in the sky and how far away it is
if something is you know 500 times away
from the sun
as far away from the sun as is the earth
you know that's planet nine that's when
the story concludes
and then you can study it right now you
can study yeah by the way
i'm going to use that as like i don't
know pick up line or a dating strategy
like see the person for three days and
then don't see them at all and then see
them again in
in a year to determine the orbit and
over time
you figure out if sort of uh
from a cosmic perspective this this
whole thing
works out i have no dating advice to
give i was good
i was gonna use this as a metaphor to uh
to somehow
map it onto the human condition
you